bueno pues en realidad esto forma parte
de un proyecto de ley que fue presentado
hoy en la reunión de gabinete que tiene
lugar cada semana aquí en francia y en
este proyecto de ley lo que se quiere es
extender el estado de emergencia o de
urgencia sanitaria hasta el finales de
julio de 2022 y esto incluye por
supuesto pasa a este controvertido pase
sanitario lo que ha explicado el
gobierno es que quieren en evitar si
digamos actuar con prudencia y en caso
de que haya una nueva ola de contagios
pues quieren contar con todas las
herramientas necesarias para poder hacer
frente a esto cuáles son esas
herramientas por ejemplo la limitación
de desplazamientos de las personas de
una región a otra los toques de queda el
cierre de establecimientos y entre ellos
pues también prolongar ese pase
sanitario que debía ir normalmente hasta
el 15 de noviembre próximo además de
esto dentro de este proyecto de ley
también se pide que se aumenten aún más
los castigos a quienes utilizan el pase
sanitario de manera fraudulenta con unas
sanciones que pueden ir a cinco años de
cárcel y hasta 75 mil de multa este
proyecto de ley va a ser por supuesto
estudiado por el parlamento el próximo
19 de octubre es decir la próxima semana
pero ya se imaginarán ustedes que hay
muchísimas personas que están criticando
esto tanto de la oposición pero incluso
también de miembros de la partido de
gobierno que quienes creen que esta
utilización del pase sanitario pues ese
coarta las libertades individuales las
libertades colectivas y el otro punto
que tampoco gusta mucho es que en caso
de que esto sea aprobado pues está esta
prolongación va a estar vigente aún
después de que manuel marco no haya
terminado su mandato mandato que llega
hasta termino el próximo mes de abril
del próximo año a menos de que se haya
reelegido y bueno en este caso quiere
decir que toda la discusión alrededor
del pase sanitario durante la campaña
presidencial pues queda completamente
descartado